in this video we'll talk about celiac
disease which is an immune reaction to
eat gluten rich food
in Celiac disease eating gluten rich
foods such as bread or wheat product can
trigger your immune response especially
in your small intestine and you feel
that burn inside your belly let's talk
about the symptoms symptoms include
anemia diarrhea gas bloating abdominal
pain in extreme cases weight loss more
rare symptoms include fatigue tiredness
joint pain itchy or blistery skin mouth
sores Etc
over time the lining of the intestine
gets eroded in case of celiac disease
and that caused many problem such as
that prevents the absorption of vitamin
B12 and vitamin B9 from the diet this is
a prime cause of anemia because both
these vitamins are associated with RBC
maturation so vitamin B9 or folic acid
is especially important for RBC
maturation when that is malabsorbed
there is problem regarding
RBC production
let's talk about the Immunology of the
celiac disease so the major problem in
the celiac disease is the gluten now
gluten has two component gladine and
glutenine gladine is the main culprit
here gladrine is pretty much pretty much
resistant to many digestive enzymes so
in the small intestine you can see a
portion of the small intestine here
gladine gets assembled with the
secretory IGA generally this immune
complex is destined to be distracted but
in rare occasions in Celiac disease
these complex is actually binding to
transferine receptor which is otherwise
important for iron absorption or iron
metabolism
now after it binds to transferring it
gets transcytosed inside the cells and
get released in the other side known as
lamina propia gladine gets further
converted to tissue transaminase and it
becomes deaminated gladine deaminated
gladine gets engulfed by Resident
macrophages
now it can present this deaminated
gladine on top of Class 2 MHC molecules
in this case there is a specific variant
of mhc2 which is HLA DQ 8 and HLA dq2
now the macrophages leads to activation
of T cells which can further secrete
inflammatory cytokine bringing up the
inflammation in your intestine also it
can activate B cells which eventually
get differentiated into plasma cells
these plasma cells secrete several
antibody which brings out the immune
response against your intestinal wall
and these antibodies include anti-tissue
transglutaminase two antibody or tg2
antibody which is also a biomarker for
diagnosing this disease
anti-deaminated gladine peptides are
also present and anti-endomycl antibody
is present in this disease as well
let's talk about the diagnosis as
mentioned earlier you can have
serological diagnosis by looking at the
presence of specific tg2 antibody in the
blood sample also there could be genetic
testing for HLA dq2 and HLA dq8 which is
more expensive in nature
anyway the treatment of celiac disease
include restriction in terms of diet so
if you have celiac disease and if you
are diagnosed with celiac disease you
should avoid gluten Rich substances and
only dietary modification can give you
some relief
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up you can get more notes
flash cards in my you if a Facebook
Channel and also in Instagram all the
links are present in the description if
you want to support our Channel click on
the thanks super thanks option you can
pay via paytm PayPal and UPI
see you in next video